well I am I'm really excited guys I the
the green New Deal is finally here I'm
super excited about it I've been waiting
forever it seems I think we've all been
waiting for it
you know Ben Shapiro called it one of
the stupidest documents ever written and
I totally disagree I mean I couldn't
disagree more this is how can you
complain about something that promises
to give you free housing free college
free health care and a livable income
even if you don't feel like working so
this is I mean how could anyone complain
about this it's great oh right because
because it's it's it's completely insane
and impossible and delusional and
childish and it's the kind of thing that
would sound brilliant if you were high
or severely concussed so okay that's
that's the reason why it's a stupid play
all right fine
let's take a look at the plan a plan by
the way that all of the most prominent
Democratic presidential candidates Cory
Booker Camilla Harris have I think five
or six of them at least have come out
and endorsed this plan and now if we had
an honest media which of course we don't
but if we did that would be fatal for
them for these Democratic candidates
because then they would they would be
forced to justify and explain every
crazy delusional idiotic thing in this
plan and it would totally discredit them
but but that's not gonna happen so the
media you know the media is not gonna
stop Cory Booker and say hey by the way
how are we gonna build a train track
across the entire ocean you know that's
that's not gonna happen because they
don't want to embarrass him so but we'll
get to that the train track thing we'll
get to in a second let me read a little
bit from this plan and we'll just kind
of we'll just you know we'll just well
we'll see what we think of it all right
so it says this is a massive
transformation of our society with clear
goals and a time line the green New Deal
resolution a ten year plan to mobilize
every aspect of American society at a
scale not seen since World War two
to achieve Net Zero greenhouse gas
emissions and create economic prosperity
for all
it will move America to 100% clean and
renewable energy create millions of
family supporting wage union jobs in
ship by the way I don't I don't want to
be a spoiler alert I guess here but at
no point does this plan explain how it's
going to create jobs that is never
explained it's just it's just stated
that they're going to create jobs I
guess what they're because if you write
it in a planet right that's all you have
to do write it down on a plan and say we
should have more jobs and then and then
just like that the jobs appear I guess
that's that's the way this works ensure
a just transition for all communities
and workers to ensure economic security
for people and communities that have
historically relied on fossil fuel
industries I don't even know what that
means what is that is that even a
sentence that's just a jumble of words
ensure a just transition for all
communities and workers to ensure
economic security what ensure justice
and equity for frontline communities by
prioritizing investment training climate
and community resiliency economic and
environmental benefits in these
communities like I said this is these
aren't even sentences okay these are
just words
Alexandra okay so Cortes had a bucket of
words that she dumped on a page and this
is it also a job with a family
sustaining wage family and medical leave
vacations and retirement security this
these are by the way now I'm listing all
the things that we're gonna get high
quality education including higher
education and trade schools clean air
and water and access to nature what to
say she's going to ensure that we all
have access to nature I think we all
have that now don't wait I mean you can
walk outside of your home if there's
anyone living maybe in some sort of
giant bio dome on Mars then they might
not have access to nature but the rest
of us do all you have to do is just walk
outside and
there you go also healthy food
high-quality health care safe affordable
adequate housing economic environment
free in an economic environment free of
monopolies monopolies economic security
for all who are unable or unwilling to
work let me in case you missed that she
is going to ensure economic security for
all who are unable or unwilling to work
so with this plan you could just say now
don't feel like working I'm just I'm not
willing sorry that's all and then if
you're not willing to work then then
what she'll do is she'll send you to so
there's going to be two magical trees
right there's going to be the affordable
the livable income tree and so if you
want to work you'll go to that mat to
that magic tree and you'll pluck a
livable income off of the tree and put
it into a basket and bring it and skip
merrily on home like Little Red Riding
Hood or if you don't want to work then
you can go to the Economic Security tree
and pluck a bit of economic security off
the tree and put that in the basket and
skip on home and that's the way that
this is going to work something tells me
that the Economic Security tree is going
to be a lot more popular than the than
the livable income tree and what we'll
get more to that in a second because
remember this is a very important part
of this that by ensuring economic
security not to mention free housing
free health care free college for
everybody even if you're not willing to
work you have just made it so that there
is no incentive to work which is a big
problem because as we'll see here in a
minute
a lot of what Cortes is talking about
here will require a lot of work there's
a lot of work that's gonna need to be
done in order for all this stuff to
happen but there's not gonna be anyone
to do the work because you've just made
it so that we can sit home on a couch
and live like kings by the way one other
thing before we get to some other
highlights or lowlights from this bill
what does any of this have to do with
the environment
there are a few things in there clean
air clean water fine but free education
free housing for everybody how what how
is that how does that help the
environment that's what I don't get I
thought this was supposed to be a green
new deal but most of this stuff has
absolutely nothing to do with the
environment one way or another so here
are some other highlights from the bill
up or the the plan I should say upgrade
or replace every building in the US for
state of the art energy efficiency yes
every building so every building not
even just every commercial building
there are there are over five million
commercial buildings in the US which
will be a big project all on its own to
update or replace five million
commercial buildings and also keep in
mind that many of those commercial
buildings are in cities and they are
like huge skyscrapers so to replace so
before we even get to anything else
she's talking about replacing almost
every skyscraper in the entire country
a skyscraper I think I read somewhere
that the I was reading recently I don't
know why about the the most expensive
buildings in the world and the World
Trade Center for instance it costs like
a billion dollars or something these
massive skyscrapers cost hundreds of
millions if not over a billion dollars
so just to replace every skyscraper
you're talking about billions upon
billions of dollars and then we get to
every retail store all the Walmart's all
that's all the shopping centers all the
malls and then all the homes too there
are 127 million households in America
now that doesn't mean that all of them
live in single-family homes like we're
also talking condominiums apartments
townhouses all that stuff there are 127
million of those and so we've got to
replace all of those as well and we
haven't even got to the the schools
churches hospitals post offices all of
that has to be replaced so
we're talking about hundreds of millions
of bill things that need to be replaced
this is what is this is going to be
trillions of dollars that she's just on
this project alone and we're only
getting started that's just the
beginning I mean this is just step one
guys to tear down every single building
in America and rebuild it from scratch
that is just step one
now we also are going to totally
overhaul transportation by massively
expanding electric vehicle manufacturing
build charging stations everywhere that
language is actually in the plan build
charging stations everywhere where are
we gonna build them everywhere just
wherever just everywhere I mean there'll
be five of them right here in this room
there will be every one they'll be
raining from the sky everywhere that's
all just everywhere so much of this plan
it reads like something that you know
she something it's it's like something
she had to come up with for her 11th
grade economics class or something like
that and you know she she forgot to do
the project and then she remembered the
night before and so she's just rushing
and writing it down like build charging
stations everywhere just put that down
and by the way this would be if this was
for an economics project in high school
this she would definitely get a failing
grade for this create affordable public
transit transit available to all
build-out high-speed rail at a scale
where air travel stops becoming
necessary ok if we are building enough
high-speed rail to make al air travel
unnecessary we would of course need this
mythical railway system primarily built
across the ocean because that is that is
when air travel is the most necessary so
if you want to make it unnecessary
there's no getting around the fact that
you are going to need a railway system
that stretches across the entire length
of the Pacific and across the entire
length of the Atlantic and you you're
probably going to need many railways
systems going across the Pacific because
the Pacific is a is a pretty large body
of water and if you only have one
railway system going across it well
that's gonna lead to a lot of congestion
and it's not going to be very accessible
to everybody so you're probably gonna
need hundreds of railroads that are just
stretching across the ocean now there is
just you know there's about 5,000 miles
separating California from Japan so this
railroad system would have to span
across 5,000 miles and it would also
have to be built over water that is
13,000 feet deep on average so you would
need a structure you would need giant
13,000 foot structures like pillars that
these that these this railroad system is
going to be built upon so this is a
project that would take I mean you got
to think probably centuries and again
cost billions and billions of dollars
and not to mention you know being out in
the middle of the Pacific trying to
install these 13,000 foot structures so
that you can build that's a very
dangerous work and we're gonna lose a
lot of lives doing this which that goes
back to the problem of who's going to
volunteer to go out into the middle of
the Pacific and build a railroad system
when you've just said that they can sit
home if they're unwilling to work and
get paid anyway another part of the plan
plant lots of trees that's an actual
sentence in the document now it this is
at least practical I mean we can plant
lots of trees but once again we see this
sort of thing where it looks like it's
dashed off at the last minute because
she was procrastinating and so we need
another thing but plant lots of trees
just put that down there what do you
mean where are we gonna plant them it
doesn't matter just plant we'll plant
lots of them that's all we just will
plant them somewhere and then and then
finally she also wants to abolish cows I
found this to be rather horrifying she
wants to get rid of cows actually
farting cows specifically but all cows
fart so
the and yes the phrase farting cows
actually appears verbatim in this
allegedly serious proposal written by
United States congresswoman and endorsed
remember by all of the prominent
Democratic presidential candidates so
here's the full context it says we set a
goal to get to Net Zero rather than zero
emissions in ten years because we aren't
sure that we'll be able to fully get rid
of farting cows and airplanes that fast
get rid of get rid of farting cows so
the implication is that getting rid of
gassy cows is a goal that they have but
she's not sure if they'll be able to do
it in ten years so that may be the most
reasonable concession that cortes makes
in this entire document when she says
okay maybe we can't get rid of every cow
now hold on a second actually you think
we can rebuild every single building in
the country build railway systems across
the Pacific provide free housing free
education free health care free income
to everyone yet getting rid of all the
cows is the thing that you're not sure
we'll be able to accomplish in ten years
that's where you get conservative all of
a sudden I mean that's one thing that we
could I don't think it would be a good
idea but we could probably get rid of
all the cows in like a week they're
pretty slow and stupid and fat I mean if
you wanted to just go and carpet-bomb
all the all the all the cattle farms or
maybe go out there with machine guns and
just and just take down all the cows you
could probably do it I mean if you sent
out maybe you sent out the some Navy
SEAL squads or I don't know you could
deploy if you needed to deploy the
military and I I think they could
probably slaughter all the cows within a
week probably so don't sell yourself
short
AOC and is that the plan you know she
says get rid of cows well are we talking
about killing all of them in some sort
of mass cow genocide or the only other
option would be well we could ship them
all off to some sort of island like cow
fart island or something but then
there's
gonna be ruining the environment with
their flatulence so the only other
option beyond that would be to launch
them into space and then you know just
send them out into interstellar space
and then maybe they'll eventually land
in some other alien civilization can you
imagine being an aliens in alien
civilization and some some spacecraft
lands and then a bunch of cows emerge
what are they gonna think I think one
thing they're gonna wonder like how did
these cows this should be an advanced
race of aliens and yet it's a bunch of
what are these it would be very
confusing for them so I don't know I
don't know what's the what's what's the
plan how is she going to pay for any of
this well she doesn't really answer that
question but in the FAQ the frequently
asked question portion of the document
it says how will you pay for it and the
answer is the same way we paid for the
New Deal the 2008 bank bailout and
extended quantitative easing programs
the same way we paid for World War two
and all our current Wars the Federal
Reserve can extend credit to power these
projects and investments and new public
banks can be created to extend credit
there's also space for the government to
take an equity stake in projects to get
a return on investment at the end of the
day this is an investment in our economy
that should grow our wealth as a nation
so the question isn't how we will pay
for it but what we will do with all of
our new shared prosperity in other words
she has no idea how we're going to pay
for it the question isn't how we're
gonna pay for it it's what are we gonna
do with all of our prosperity that's the
question which is just the classic line
of a conman trying to sell you something
no no don't worry about how you're gonna
pay for it just think about it's like
someone who's trying to sell you on a
pyramid scheme
and so then rather than explaining the
details of the plan they show you
pictures of like nice watches
and fancy houses and cars and you're
asking questions why wait how is this
gonna work with it no don't worry about
how it's gonna work just think about how
you're gonna spend all the money you're
gonna make
now I was thinking about this in listen
it's really easy to make fun of this
plan and to be a Debbie Downer and a
naysayer it's really easy to do because
it's such an enormous ly stupid idea but
that I was also thinking listen if we're
gonna do this thing let's go all the way
you could actually argue that the green
new deal the the main problem with it is
that it's too modest if if you're if
we're gonna do it let's do this thing
that's what I'm saying also think about
the fact that if if they have the
ability to do this then they must have
access to not only trillions of dollars
but even like magical genies and wizards
who can who can because most of this
stuff is impossible without magical
super powers and so if they have access
which I assume that Alexandria kZO
Cortes must if she has access to a team
of highly-trained genies then I've got
some other ideas this is my idea for let
we could call it a new green New Deal or
maybe a green new New Deal whatever you
want to call it I have just a few things
actually have 20 things I would like to
add to the deal and I just want to offer
these up as a suggestion number one a
free ice cream machine for every
American and of course this would have
to be vegan ice cream because Cortes is
killing all the milk cows remember
number two every sidewalk in America
converted to a moving walkway at number
three every staircase converted to an
escalator number for every escalator
converted to an elevator number five I'm
thinking of a big bridge connecting
North Carolina to like Morocco okay with
like refreshment stands and stuff along
the way and then you would also probably
need like some cabins or something so
people can stop and sleep because they
might get yeah it's kind of
kind of a long walk number six a free
blimp for every American number seven a
free dog for every person number eight a
free foot bath for every dog number nine
essential oils for every foot bath
because you don't want to take a foot
bath if you're not going to be
exfoliating your skin at the same time
number ten this to me seems really
obvious instead of and this is where I'm
showing you Cortese she's not thinking
big enough here because she's saying
well let's have free health care for
everyone I've got a better idea
let's just abolish disease okay so how
about we say no more diseases and then
you don't need health care I mean think
about it this is obvious stuff right
number eleven Universal happiness you
know I think it's something we should
include in the plan number twelve
a constantly refreshed selection of
cereal in every pantry number thirteen
I'm thinking we need like magical Lions
that can read us stories and grant
wishes number fourteen immortality you
know III think again if we're if we're
gonna be doing this why not immortality
number fifteen I'm thinking every person
should have this computer type thing
like from the matrix or you can plug in
and learn how to do karate in five
minutes that would be pretty sweet
number sixteen bananas that never rot
number seventeen let's abolish
loneliness nobody's allowed to be lonely
anymore number nineteen free pony rides
for everyone but consensual pony rides
of course number nineteen I'm thinking
of every person should have kind of like
a robot thing that lifts you out of bed
in the morning and brushes your teeth
for you and puts on your pants for you
and number twenty finally and this and
this is really the the highlight of my
plan of the the things that I would add
to her plan I think that student loan
debt should be converted into tacos and
I'll tell you how this would work every
dollar of student loan debt that you
have equals one taco so if you have
thirty thousand dollars of debt well
then you get thirty thousand tacos you
see I mean pretty it's like how it
hasn't anyone thought of this yet we've
got all this debt if you change it into
tacos
then the debts gone and now you have
tacos so hope I'm een come on right so
that's my plan I you know I was I'm
gonna write this up in an official
proposal and send it to Alexandria
Kaiser Cortez's office and hopefully
she'll add that to the plan so we'll
well you know stay tuned for that all
right I hate to I hate to keep talking
about this woman
but Cortez she also spoke at a rally
yesterday was a bit busy day for her
they were some progressive members of
Congress were rallying against ice and
sea CBP the Customs and Border
Protection they were rallying against
their own law enforcement agencies
because the thing that they're upset
about is that these agencies enforce the
law they don't like that I want you to
listen to one thing the Cortes said at
this rally all right here's the clip of
it right now because we are standing on
native land and Latino people are
descendants of Native people and we
cannot be told and criminalized simply
for our identity or our status okay she
says we are standing on native land and
Latino people are descendants of Native
people and we cannot be told and
criminalized simply for our identity and
our status so many problems here
goodness gracious
there there are many problems here let's
start with the greatest irony of all
Cortes said this Alexandria okay zo
Cortes where do you think that name came
from I can tell you this okay
there weren't many Aztecs with names
like that you're not gonna find
Alexandria Cortes among the Aztecs it
just so happens the
Cortez shares a last name with the most
famous conquistador in history Hernan
Cortes why because people from Central
America many of them are actually
descended from the Spanish from Spanish
Europeans now so so now I don't know
this as a fact I'm just saying that she
well I know as a fact that's that many
people from Central America from Central
America are descended in part from
Spanish Europeans I don't know that
Alexandria Kaiser Cortez is related to
Hernan Cortes but they do have the same
last name and now I happen to think that
Hernan Cortes is one of the great heroes
of Western civilization because he
overthrew an evil violent empire a vial
of ruthless human sacrifices but still
the point remains that Alexandria may
well be descended from the guy who came
here on a boat and overthrew a native
civilization now it's true that people
from Central and South America also are
likely descended from native people as
well so they're most of them are a mix
just as most people everywhere in the
world are a mix of different ethnicities
and and cultures and so on but think
about what what she's doing here she's
treating and this is very common the
left they do this all the time where
they treat native people like a monolith
as if as if someone who is partially
descended from a tribe in Central
America like the Aztecs also has some
kind of rightful claim to the
continental US which makes no sense
whatsoever it's like saying that
somebody from Italy has a birthright
claim to to France or someone from
Sweden has a rightful claim to Norway or
someone from from from Ghana has a
rightful claim to Nigeria okay it points
guests because your ancestors came from
a certain hemisphere or continent
doesn't mean that your birthright gives
you access to that entire section of the
globe
Indians or native people or indigenous
people or whatever phrase you want to
use these were not this was not one
homogenous unified group they were
fractured separate distinct different
people they didn't consider themselves
there was no they didn't consider
themselves to be one big giant unified
people because they weren't now
sometimes they lived in cooperation with
the tribes around them sometimes they
enslaved and killed each other which
again you find that all across the world
that's the way that it's always worked
but they were different so it just
doesn't make any sense at all someone
who lives in Mexico now there's a very
good chance that they are descended from
Spanish Europeans and also perhaps
native tribes from Central America but
that by no means implies that they are
also natives to the continental US that
just doesn't make any sense whatsoever
all right that's enough of talking about
this woman can't stomach anymore I want
to read let's get to the inbox before we
wrap up for the week here Matt Walsh
show at gmail.com Matt Walsh Oh
gmail.com you can email your thoughts
questions concerns hate mail whatever
you got this is from ash it says my
second grader is doing a project on MLK
Jr where he's supposed to dress up as
the leader and give a report Oh
each kid in the class has a different
historical figure and my son got MLK he
was so excited when he came home to tell
me and wanted to discuss his costume
costume I told him that we could put him
in a suit and draw the facial hair but
that we couldn't darken his skin because
it wasn't right he's eight so he got
upset but I explained that it wasn't
appropriate because it hurt the feelings
of people of color and and eventually he
was fine with that but he rightfully I
think doesn't think anyone will get his
costume there is absolutely no way I
would put my little boy in blackface
even though he only wants
to honor the former civil rights hero my
question is given the current climate
why would they give a wittle little
white boy this assignment I am super
proud that he wants to honor MLK and his
presentation will be awesome but I am
put off by the fact that he that they
asked him to dress up in costume to do
it it feels like entrapment for his
potential future aspirations yeah I mean
I agree that the school should have
known better than this in this
environment you really are setting a kid
up for for some problems if you ask a
white kid to dress up as MLK I mean I
it's amazing to me especially given
everything that's happened over the past
week that the school has an assignment
to dress up like some historical figure
and they assign MLK to a white kid and
say dress up like him I mean it's just
yeah but this also just shows how crazy
our culture has become because you
shouldn't have to worry about this as a
parent at all everyone should just
understand that he's a young child
dressing as someone he admires so it
should be a total non-issue but our
culture is so crazy and so unreasonable
people are so unreasonable and looking
to just we're looking to destroy each
other for the smallest little reason
that now this is something you have to
worry about and I think that's just a
although it was stupid on the part of
the school it's also more than that it
is a it is a reflection of the insanity
of our culture that you as the parent
even have to worry about that okay this
is from someone who I'm not sure if they
want me to use their name or not so I so
I won't just to be safe it says hi Matt
I just wanted to say I love your show i
watch it pretty much every day I'd like
to share with you my story I was 19 and
I got pregnant because I was not on
birth control since I thought it
wouldn't happen to me I was still fresh
a freshman in college and did not want a
baby to quote ruin my education and
career I was considering abortion even
though I knew it was wrong however my
boyfriend who was also still in school
stepped up and convinced me to keep the
baby he told me that it was his baby too
and that I can't just abort his child he
promised
that he would support me now we are
married with two amazing kids I never
finished my degree but I do not regret
it at all
I am content because of the joy my
babies bring to everyone in my family I
wish that more men would be like my
husband and own up to their actions
abortion is not just a woman's issue it
takes two to make a baby men need to
stop running away from their families
it's really scary to see that some
people don't understand that abortion is
murder I didn't fully understand it when
I was young but after becoming a mother
I honestly cannot fathom how abortion is
legal it makes my blood boil that babies
are murdered every day and it's done by
medical professionals anyway love the
show keep doing what you're doing well I
would say keep doing what you're doing
thank you for sharing that story it's an
awesome story both you and your
husband's are heroes in my book and it's
really incredible and really great to
hear a story about a man stepping up
like that speaking up for his child and
being encouraging and supportive to you
know his pregnant girlfriend and there
are many stories like this that don't
get highlighted but still not not enough
not nearly enough and I totally agree
with you that you know when we when we
talk about abortion as a women's issue
it has it's it's unfair to men and it
also lets men off the hook too much so
it's unfair to the good men and it lets
the lazy scumbag men off the hook and
it's also just incorrect as you point
out it takes two people to make a baby
so there are a lot of men out there
unfortunately there are plenty of
cowardly lazy just bad men who are
perfectly happy to talk about abortion
being a woman's issue and say look I
have no opinion I can't have any opinion
they can do what they want because it it
completely absolves them of all Hill so
they can go get women pregnant and then
they say it's your issue to deal with
fine go ahead yeah go ahead and kill the
babies fine but then they're also good
men out there who what they're
being told is that when they create a
child when they create a human being
that that's not their child they have no
say they have no right and that's just
completely wrong but anyway thank you
for sharing that inspirational story I
really appreciate it
and finally this is from Brad he says hi
Matt I'm a huge fan in show I share your
political views 100% and your religious
views for the most part I also
appreciate your stance on homeschooling
as I was home-schooled and my wife and I
plan to homeschool our daughter when she
reaches the age I am writing in regards
to your show comments from earlier in
the week about whether infants go to
heaven or hell I come from the Reformed
Calvinist point of view and I must
disagree on your position as hard as it
is to think about from a human
perspective I do not believe that we can
assume all infants are spared hell and
go straight to heaven as a Calvinist
Christian we ascribe to the doctrine of
election and reprobation I am not sure
how Catholics such as yourself you this
doctrine but we believe that all people
that have ever been and will ever be on
this earth are in two camps the elect
and the reprobate as Christians we
believe only those written in the book
of life will enter heaven all the others
are cast into hell and we also believe
all people are conceived and born with
the curse of the original sin so even an
infant while not capable of actual sin
is still guilty of original sin I
believe the children of believers are
granted the reward of eternal life if
they pass it an early stage but I do not
believe we can assume the same for
unbelievers the Bible clearly states
that only the chosen will enter Heaven
therefore I believe it is dangerous to
assume God makes an exception for all
infants I realize it is a terrible thing
to think about but I think it is the
truth I hope you see what I'm trying to
articulate here I'm far from a
theologian or an expert by any stretch
just a simple farm boy raised in a
conservative country Church I look
forward to response from you
hi Brad I appreciate your email and your
support for the show I don't mean this
with any hostility whatsoever so please
understand that but I have to say that I
find this and I know that you're far
from the only person that has this point
of view and you articulated the point of
view quite eloquently and so I
appreciate
but I do find that point of view to be
horrific honestly let's put this into
perspective here okay you're talking
about hell okay so this is not some
theoretical in-between place right
you're you're talking about Hell Hell
like actual Hell a place of eternal
torment I assume is what you mean by
hell and also when we talk about the
word eternal eternal means very little
to us because we can't possibly wrap our
heads around what it means what we don't
know what forever means we can only
experience time in succession and so
every moment a moment comes it runs out
we get another moment and that's how we
experience time which makes it just
impossible to think about eternity and
so sometimes I think were able to you
know maybe there are some people that
are able to and I'm not saying you're
doing this but maybe there are some
people were able to sort of casually say
yeah maybe some babies go to hell for
all eternity because they don't even
think about what eternity means because
none of us can really conceive which is
why when I've been talking about this
this week I've been saying well you're
talking about babies going to hell for
trillions of years and I've had some
people send me emails and say well you
can't say hell is trillions of years
that's inaccurate this is eternity
you're talking about in terms of time
yeah I understand that but I'm just
trying to put it in terms that we can
sort of understand now we can't
understand a trillion years either we
can't even understand a million years
but at least a number is something that
we can sort of wrap our head around the
point anyway is that hell we believe is
forever never ends so to say it's a
trillion years is really a trillion year
stacked up against eternity is just a
drop in the bucket the trillion years
you haven't even gotten started yet so
you're saying that God a merciful a
perfectly merciful and loving being
might send babies think about a
six-month-old baby might send a six
month
old baby who dies of a disease or is
killed and a flood or fire something may
send that being who he created to
eternal torment that never ever ever
ever ends worse you're saying that they
were selected that that child let's just
put this you know let's narrow this down
a little bit
imagine a six-month-old child who dies
let's say in a house fire okay these
things happen
child of an unbeliever the child dies in
agonizing pain and then goes to an
eternity of agonizing pain that God has
selected that child for and you're
saying that the child was selected for
that before birth he never had any
choice
he never had any say in it he never had
any role in this at all
he never had any direct personal role in
his own damnation God selected him for
Hell and then made him and sent him to
earth and then took his life almost
immediately and cast him into an
eternity of suffering and you suggest
that this could somehow be in keeping
with a merciful and loving creator but I
think you know that it's not which is
why you even say it's terrible it's
terrible it's hard you don't use word
like terrible you're right it is
terrible but a loving creator doesn't do
terrible things um keep something else
in mind you know he could have just not
made the baby in the first place
creation for God is an active choice so
he must choose to make this baby and he
must choose to consign before birth
before he even has conceived the child
ikan signs this child to an eternity of
suffering
and there is zero chance of anything
else happening why even make the child
then what was the point yeah we talked
about the the creation of human life as
this great miracle well it's it's not I
mean in that case he has made this
creature to suffer that's the only
reason it exists and it will never have
anything else what was even the point
and I know you could say well you know
we why would God make anyone who he
knows is gonna go to hell yeah but it's
entirely different if it's a person
who's lived long enough to make some
kind of choice someone who has had some
sort of chance who can play some sort of
direct role in all of this but a baby
who has been preordained for hell and
then taken from this world by disease or
murder has no chance no choice nothing
and will be punished forever forever for
a sin that he did not personally and
consciously commit keep one other thing
in mind bread nothing exists without
God's continual and active consent so
imagine that there is like in heaven
right now there is a Matt Walsh button
and God has his finger on the Matt Walsh
button and the moment that he releases
his finger from that button I cease to
exist of course that's not really how it
works but my point is that every moment
that I exist is an active choice by God
to keep me in exist it isn't let's say
an inactive effort by God to keep me in
existence that's what it means to be the
sovereign power reigning over all of
existence which means that those babies
suffering forever in hell God has to
sustain them in existence so that they
can continue to be tormented forever so
every moment of eternity God has to make
the active choice to keep those babies
existing so that they can suffer forever
and you imagine that a loving and
merciful God would do that it just
doesn't make any sense and I think you
know that it doesn't make any sense
but you think that you
have to be open to that possibility
because of some doctrine and what I'm
saying is that if your doctrine flies in
the face of everything we know about God
and everything we've been told about it
and your doctrine forces you to accept
the possibility that God would do
something evil and I can't think of any
other way to explain to design a child
to suffer forever in hell and to
pre-ordained him to that fate what else
if again if that is not evil then I
don't know what the word evil means so
yes I I I just absolutely reject that
that notion but it's been an interesting
conversation this week to continually
talk about this and I appreciate all
your emails on it and thanks for
watching and listening and I'll talk to
you guys next week
Godspeed